[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y esto es aqui
américa el espacio de france 24 para
revisar en profundidad las historias de
nuestro continente filibusterismo una
táctica que está de moda en eeuu con la
nueva configuración del senado en la que
hay un empate de sillas entre
republicanos y demócratas revisamos de
qué se trata el procedimiento utilizado
históricamente para retrasar o bloquear
una acción en la cámara alta del
congreso
y por primera vez las cifras de
homicidios en el salvador van cayendo en
picada un equipo de france 24 que viajó
al país centroamericano determinó que
puede haber una colusión entre pandillas
y el gobierno para lograr esta
disminución de la violencia y un año
después de la prematura muerte de la
leyenda del básquetbol kobe bryant el
dolor que provoca su muerte solo lo
iguala el legado que dejó atrás
y vamos de inmediato a eeuu para nuestra
historia principal
este 2021 las ciencias del senado están
divididas de manera equitativa entre
republicanos y demócratas 50-50 dejando
en manos de la vicepresidenta kamala
harris como presidenta del senado el
dirimir los empates previsiblemente a
favor de los demócratas su partido con
medidas tan importantes en juego como
una reforma migratoria que abriría un
camino a la ciudadanía para los más de
11 millones de indocumentados que hay en
la unión americana trabajar de manera
bipartidista se ha vuelto crucial el
lunes el líder de la minoría republicana
en el senado mitch mcconnell anunció que
está de acuerdo con compartir el poder
después de que algunos legisladores
demócratas se negarán a que se eliminara
la práctica del filibusterismo
el fili que se trata de una maniobra de
obstrucción utilizada desde 1840 con la
que el partido minoritario tiene la
oportunidad de bloquear un proyecto de
ley y los republicanos sí que tienen la
intención de usarla les explicamos de
qué se trata una vez fue una herramienta
política poco utilizada en los últimos
años el filibusterismo se ha convertido
en casi la norma en el senado de eeuu el
partido minoritario la usa para bloquear
importantes proyectos de ley un proyecto
de ley se puede aprobar con mayoría
simple una vez que se votó pero cuando
los miembros no están de acuerdo sobre
si someterlo a votación la minoría puede
tratar de debatir para que no se vote a
esto se le llama felix booster la
táctica de demora tiene su raíz en la
tradición estadounidense de que el
senado la cámara alta del congreso es un
lugar de debate ilimitado o portavoz en
2010 el demócrata bernie sanders
obstruyó durante ocho horas y media un
proyecto para reformar la ley de
impuestos cinco años después el
republicano rand paul habló durante 13
horas para tratar de bloquear la ley
patriótica pasajes de la biblia recetas
de cocina e historias para dormir a los
niños han sido leídas en el capitolio en
el pasado
y esta obstrucción solo se puede detener
cuando el orador deja de hablar o cuando
tres quintos de los 100 miembros del
senado están de acuerdo para ponerle fin
al debate un proceso que se conoce como
cierre o guillotina actualmente una
legislación es comúnmente bloqueada por
más de 40 senadores oponiéndose a ella
sin necesidad del filibusterismo el
nuevo senado estadounidense está
dividido equitativamente entre
republicanos y demócratas y la
vicepresidenta kamala harris como
presidenta del senado tiene el voto para
romper un empate desde el principio las
conversaciones sobre como la cámara
debería funcionar han quedado en punto
muerto el líder republicano mitch
mcconnell pidió que se preserven el
filibusterismo y sólo accedió a un
acuerdo para compartir el poder después
de obtener garantías verbales de algunos
demócratas de que se opondrían a
eliminar la herramienta y la forma
avanzar en un senado 50-50 es tener
cosas que llamen a 60 votos en el
calendario legislativo
el líder demócrata chuck schumer
advirtió que la mayoría podría usar otra
herramienta para aprobar el proyecto de
ley de alivio de la pandemia del
presidente joe biden
de essence el tiempo es crucial para
atender esta crisis estamos manteniendo
todas las opciones sobre la mesa incluso
usar un presupuesto de reconciliación
cvr el debate sobre el filibusterismo
está lejos de acabarse quienes lo apoyan
lo ven como una manera de asegurar que
las minorías tengan una voz quienes se
oponen lo ven como desactualizado y
obstructivo y seguimos en eeuu que es la
nación más golpeada por el cob y 19 por
cada 4 casos en el mundo hay un
estadounidense el presidente yo walken
está trabajando para detener el
crecimiento de esa cifra al agilizar la
distribución de las vacunas quiere que
300 millones de sus ciudadanos estén
vacunados para finales del verano pero
es una meta difícil de alcanzar debido a
la escasez de vacunas que es tan severa
que cientos de miles de citas para
aplicar la inyección han sido canceladas
en eeuu no faltan las dosis de vacunas
pero llevarlas a donde se necesitan es
un inmenso desafío logístico desde que
el país empezó a aplicarlas el 14 de
diciembre más de 20 millones de
estadounidenses han sido inmunizados eso
es poco más del 6% de la población
si bien la vacuna despierta tanta
esperanza a la distribución es un
verdadero fracaso entiendo la
desesperación y frustración de muchos
estadounidenses imagino cómo se sienten
huddersfield
incluso con una cita los neoyorquinos no
están seguros de recibir la vacuna
está cancelado que me dijeron que
vinieran una semana más que tuviera
bragas no ves ya ve a hacer no sé porque
yo deben demandar de mandarle a decía 11
de una persona mayor para esto se están
formando largas filas fuera de los
centros de vacunación como en este
estadio de los ángeles cuando llegamos
una espera de tres a cuatro horas
hablamos con un bombero y nos dijo que
volviéramos esta mañana usted que mermó
de estos jóvenes californianos no son
una prioridad para recibir la vacuna por
lo que han decidido acampar afuera para
tratar de obtener las dosis sobrantes
si esta vacuna se tira a la basura cuál
es el punto si somos lo suficientemente
jóvenes y saludables como para pasar la
noche afuera y obtenerla es mejor que
nos la apliquen
para acelerar el programa de vacunación
dos gigantes minoristas han ofrecido sus
servicios a la casablanca
amazon para ayudar a entregar las dosis
y walmart para abrir centros de
vacunación en sus supermercados
y méxico también ha sido duramente
golpeado por el coronavirus esta semana
el presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador dio positivo por kobe 19 el
mandatario había sido un escéptico de
las medidas de bioseguridad tenemos una
mirada a la gestión de la pandemia de
lópez obrador en el siguiente informe de
natalia plazas
el presidente del país andrés manuel
lópez obrador dio positivo por
coronavirus el mandatario ha sido
fuertemente criticado por la gestión que
ha hecho de la pandemia de coronavirus
en el país desde el inicio de la
emergencia
minimizó su impacto siento que no vamos
a atender problemas mayores y mientras
otros países de la región imponían
restricciones su administración se
resistía no dejen
salir todavía estamos en la primera fase
ya nosotros yo les voy a decir cuando no
salga a pesar de haber sufrido un
infarto y padecer hipertensión rara vez
se le ha visto con una mascarilla en
público a lo largo de la pandemia ha
continuado sus viajes y mítines por
diferentes puntos del país y ha seguido
saludando a sus simpatizantes con
apretones de manos y abrazos donde el
coronavirus esos de que esto no se puede
uno abraza hay que abrazar se promovió
dudosos métodos para una supuesta
protección ante el contagio de este ente
detente
ahora hablo se une a otros líderes
mundiales que han contraído la
enfermedad como el ex presidente
estadounidense donald trump el
presidente brasileño jair bolsonaro o el
primer ministro británico boris johnson
también ellos restaron importancia al
impacto del virus y se negaron al inicio
de la pandemia a imponer restricciones y
hay buenas noticias desde el salvador la
tasa de criminalidad va en picada una
rara señal de esperanza en un país que
ha tenido la cifra de homicidios más
alta del mundo la más reciente fue en
2015 con 103 asesinatos por cada 100.000
habitantes un frenesí de muertes
violentas alimentado por los
enfrentamientos entre bandas criminales
que continúan reclutando masivamente a
jóvenes salvadoreños en 2019 la tasa
cayó a 19 homicidios por cada 100.000
habitantes pero lo que hay detrás de esa
caída es preocupante como nos lo explica
nuestro equipo en san salvador
pandilleros con esposas en los medios de
comunicación salvadoreños una imagen que
la policía quiere que vea la gente el
salvador ha registrado una drástica
caída en los homicidios desde la llegada
del presidente en allí bukele en 2019 en
el centro de san salvador la capital la
atmósfera de hecho es diferente pues
específicamente en este año es que ha
bajado bastante y antes no se podía
venir una santa
aquí era bien peligroso antes primero de
todo mundo todavía trata los
enfrentamientos entre pandillas que
alimentaban la violencia endémica del
país centroamericano han disminuido en
los últimos diez años pero algunos son
escépticos a este respiro entre ellos el
pastor mario vega en los barrios no ha
ocurrido ninguna dinámica ni de parte
del estado ni de parte de las pandillas
en sí sino que la baja en homicidios se
debe a un acuerdo que hay entre el
actual gobierno y la alta dirigencia de
las pandillas
pero el secreto salió a la luz carlos
martínez es un periodista investigativo
ayuda a hacer públicos cientos de
documentos oficiales que avergonzaron al
gobierno
estos documentos describen una serie
completamente anómala de visitas de
funcionarios de gobierno a la cárcel de
máxima seguridad para sostener reuniones
con líderes de la mara salvatrucha 13
que es la pandilla más grande del
salvador revelan como el gobierno
ofreció favores para mejorar la vida en
prisión a cambio los jefes de las
pandillas acordaron controlar a sus
hombres y apoyar al partido de gobierno
en las elecciones legislativas una
tregua que puede romperse en la primera
disputa desencadenando más violencia sin
embargo de acuerdo con el director de la
policía nacional todo está bajo control
en gobiernos anteriores han habido
iniciativas de las treguas de trabajar
conjuntamente con los grupos criminales
pero
el liderazgo del señor presidente a
nadie bukele yo doy fe que a mí en
ningún momento me han dicho mire va a ir
a trabajar con líderes de grupos
criminales todas las negociaciones
treguas y acuerdos secretos muestran una
cosa las pandillas lograron convertirse
en actores clave de la política
salvadoreña hace un año la leyenda del
básquetbol kobe bryant y su hija de 13
años fallecieron en un accidente de
helicóptero en california los seguidores
conmemoraron al deportista mientras las
investigaciones del hecho continúan
fuera del estadio donde kobe bryant se
convirtió en una leyenda un memorial
improvisado honrar a la estrella del
baloncesto y a su hija jana
ha pasado un año desde que murieron pero
el recuerdo aún está fresco para sus
fanáticos
solo tenía que estar aquí hoy no importa
la multitud de lo que sea
es difícil aceptarlo porque siempre que
enciendes el tv juegan los lakers es
como si estuviera presente también han
llegado homenajes de ex compañeros de
equipo y colegas de móvil para mí lo más
importante fue un padre increíble así
que para mí es la tragedia del
fallecimiento de kobe que era un padre
increíble y estaba empezando a
embarcarse en ese capítulo de su vida
bryant y su hija iban camino a un torneo
de baloncesto juvenil cuando su
helicóptero se estrelló al pie de las
montañas de santa mónica nueve personas
murieron en el incidente se cree que el
mal tiempo fue un factor ya que había
una espesa niebla el día del accidente
la vida de brian está entablando una
demanda por homicidio culposo contra el
empleador del piloto del helicóptero
alegando que la compañía no estaba
autorizada a volar bajo las condiciones
una investigación de la junta nacional
de seguridad en el transporte está
programada para entregar sus hallazgos
el 9 de febrero
y me despido desde medellín colombia
una serenata en la unidad de cuidados
intensivos esa es la iniciativa música
por la vida con la que las autoridades
de la ciudad llevan a los artistas a los
hospitales para ayudar a pacientes
familiares y los empleados de la salud
trabajando en la primera línea de
batalla contra el coronavirus a lidiar
con los efectos que tiene la pandemia
del cob y 19 en la salud mental
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa sigan viendo france24
[Música]